minneapolis other cities new york city
preparing for potential unrest at this
hour
this despite a jury finding former
police officer
derrick shoven guilty on all charges
second degree murder
third degree murder and second degree
manslaughter in the horrific death of
george floyd chauvin's bail has now been
revoked
he is in jail tonight with sentencing to
take place eight weeks from now
and tonight he is facing the likelihood
of decades behind bars
the video evidence in this case it was
substantial it was overwhelming
and it was appalling the jury arrived
with their verdict less than 24 hours
after being handed the case not a single
question
asked by the jury to the judge for nine
minutes and 29 seconds
then officer chauvin shoved his knee
into the neck of george floyd who was
handcuffed and on the ground
and co chauvin continued to apply
pressure to floyd's neck as we have
discussed on this program
the most vulnerable part of the human
anatomy
even after floyd was handcuffed saying
he can't breathe and fully complying
with the police
the crowd that had gathered urged the
officer to please stop
the knee stayed on george floyd's neck
even after he went unconscious
and the chief of police testified at
this trial
this is not what officers are trained to
do so let me be clear
this is in no way an indictment of all
police officers
this is a guilty verdict for one police
officer
everywhere unlike others on this program
we do make the distinction
we talk about the 99 percent of good
police officers that risk their lives
daily
to protect and serve their communities
they have
a very hard job and it's getting harder
every day
we made that distinction often when we
exposed the deep state corruption at the
highest levels of the fbi
the one percent not the 99 percent that
do their jobs honorably in the fbi
this trial was about the destructive and
unlawful actions of one person
and now the jury has spoken but well not
everyone in the mob in the media is
particularly happy
ms dnc contributor one there is not
happy according to him
a guilty verdict on every charge
just isn't enough take a look i actually
always thought that he would be found
guilty because it's sort of a cultural
makeup call
but i'm not happy i'm not pleased i
don't have any sense of satisfaction i
don't think this is a system working
i don't think this is a good thing this
is not the system working this is a
makeup call this is
the justice system trying to say that
hey this is one bad apple because that's
how this is going to be interpreted
it's going to be this one bad apple he
got in trouble yay
blah blah blah reckless irresponsible
rhetoric
but predictable the jury found that the
officer was guilty on every single
charge according to johnson
only a radical reform will bring about
true justice will
radical reform defund the police
dismantle the entire police
dismantle our entire system how do you
think that's going to work out in the
end congresswoman ocasio-cortez
the leader of the quote squad she agrees
she would also like to use floyd's death
to achieve her
radical ideas like disarming police
during traffic stops
will somebody maybe please last week the
tape was released of a
quote routine traffic stop and that new
mexico officer was shot
dead maybe send it to the congresswoman
take a look
it's not justice and i'll explain to you
why it's not justice
it's not justice because justice
is george floyd going home tonight
to be with his family justice
is adam toledo
getting tucked in by his mom tonight
justice is
when you're pulled over they're not
being
a gun that's part of that interaction
because you have a headlight out
remember congresswoman ocasio-cortez a
few other radical members of congress
they're the ones in charge of this
democratic socialist party the green new
deal it's not joe biden
i don't even know if he knows what day
it is he gets blown over by the wind on
any given day we're told
it's certainly not kamala harris
apparently also got blown over by the
wind
today and it's not nancy pelosi or chuck
schumer nancy pelosi speaker and name
only
now biden schumer pelosi they follow the
squad's agenda
so it's no surprise that just moments
ago joe biden echoed
congresswoman ocasio-cortez vowed for
changes for america
but that's not all biden also called on
americans to protest
with purpose what did he mean here take
a look
the murder of george floyd launched a
summer protest
we hadn't seen since the civil rights
year in the 60s
protests that unified people of every
race and generation
in peace and with purpose to say enough
enough enough of this senseless killings
protests with a purpose is that what
happened last summer joe
when you didn't have the courage to
speak out against the violent riots
that were taking place on a nightly
basis all over the country
you didn't even mention it at the
democratic national convention not
one time when a police precinct was
burned to the ground in minneapolis
downtown portland was on fire for weeks
seattle rioters took over
several city blocks including a police
precinct
multiple young people were murdered
during that so-called
summer of love chaz chop autonomous zone
spaghetti potluck dinner zone
and then you chose kamala harris a
person who promoted the bail fund
to get rioters out of jail in
minneapolis remember during the height
of the violence she said quote
they're not going to stop and everyone
you beware because they're not going to
stop
they're not going to stop before
election day in november they're not
going to stop after election day
and everyone should take note of that on
both levels
they're not going to let up and they
should not
and we should not well now we're facing
another what summer of violence
but instead of calming tensions and
calling for justice
biden is pouring yep fuel on the fire on
multiple occasions he said that america
is slipping back into
jim crow calling the georgia voting law
bill
jim crow 2.0 or jim crow in the 21st
century
which by the way the voting law in
georgia is
far more there's far more access
for every person in georgia than his
home state of delaware the one he called
the slave state
as a matter of fact for 50 years he
never lifted a finger
to make voting more accessible in the
state of delaware
17 days early in person voting in
georgia
none in delaware zero drop boxes in
delaware
but yeah in georgia they have a box in
every precinct
and by the way both states require voter
id
so how's that jim crow 2.0 it's this
kind of recklessly responsible rhetoric
from politicians
that divides this country by the way
this this is a bill that standardizes
drop boxes and
mail in voting and both states require
voter i d
on absentee ballots in order to score
cheap political points
joe biden brings up jim crow 2.0
democrats now believe that they can win
votes by what vilifying america
this is not a perfect country we've said
that many times
but through our history we have our
system of justice we have a constitution
our founders our framers they put in
place a system to right wrongs and
correct injustices
and americans have proven to do so over
and over again
many fought and died to end slavery
remember the civil rights show
act of civil rights act of 1964
the voting rights act of 1965 again
major steps towards a more perfect union
and by the way joe biden
key democrats filibustered those bills
including your good friend that you
praised often
robert byrd the former klansmen the guy
that you
partnered with in the 70s to stop
integration of our schools you didn't
want them to become
your words racial jungles and tonight
joe biden said that we need to confront
racial disparities
isn't it wasn't he the author of the 94
crime bill
the one that put so many
african-americans behind bars
as dana lash put it quote the irony of a
politician who championed
segregation and authored the crime bill
now lecturing
on systemic racism is pretty something
and meanwhile in a
very bizarre speech over in the house
nancy pelosi essentially
thanked george floyd for what for taking
one for the team
are you kidding me watch this
thank you george floyd for sacrificing
your life for justice
for being there to call out to your mom
how
how heartbreaking was that call out for
your mom
i can't breathe but because of you and
because of
thousands millions of people around the
world who came out
for justice your name will always be
synonymous
with justice speaker pelosi
george floyd was killed and by the way
today's guilty verdict
was put in jeopardy by one of your own
colleagues prior to the verdict many on
the left
seemingly trying to influence this
jury's decision
this morning joe biden announced that he
was praying the jury would do the right
thing and
deliver the right verdict even called
the family of george floyd
while the jury was out deliberating
meanwhile congresswoman maxine waters
was busy lobbing
threats of violence encouraging more
confrontational riots
if chauvin wasn't found guilty on all
three counts watch this
verdict that is a guilty guilty guilty
and not just manslaughter right i mean
oh no not bachelor
no no no for murder we got to stay on
the street
uh and we've got to get more active
we've got to get more confrontation
we got to make sure that they they know
that we need business
and keep in mind that maxine waters has
broadly vilified police for years yet
according to the daily wire
she requested police protection how
ironic
for her trip to minnesota by the way i
haven't noticed many congressmen or
women or senators
uh saying defund the capitol police
remember she made comments that you just
heard
even judge peter cahill who's presiding
over the chauvin trial
called heretic rhetoric abhorrent and
said that maxine waters statements
could be used by the defense as grounds
for a future appeal
watch this i'll give you the
congresswoman
waters may have given you something on
appeal
that may result in this whole trial
being overturned i wish elected
officials would stop
talking about this case especially in a
manner that is disrespectful
to the rule of law and to the judicial
branch in our function
i think if they want to give their
opinions they should do so in a
respectful
and in a manner that is consistent with
their oath to the constitution
to respect the co-equal branch of
government
their failure to do so i think is
abhorrent
now according to harvard law professor
alan dershowitz what maxine waters did
coupled with the judge refusing to
sequester the jury
could lead to the u.s supreme court
ultimately reversing
this conviction now time will tell if
dershowitz is right but of course
it's grounds for an appeal as the judge
just said
a sitting member of congress calling on
people to take to the streets
and get confrontational if they if she
didn't get
her desired verdict so where are all the
democrats
months ago they were the ones that were
obsessed with the term
insurrection and deeply concerned they
said
about law and order where are they
tonight you can call them i guess the
insurrectionist caucus
the ones that were silent all last
summer when
rioting was breaking out all over the
country what it's only insurrection or
rioting
if they can use it against donald trump
and republicans as a political wedge
virtually no one on the left is
condemning waters remarks no one
and by the way this is not the first
time maxine waters has called for
violence numerous times it's not even
close
you likely remember some of these great
moments
you need to respect the chair and shut
your mouth
you see anybody from that cabinet in a
restaurant
[Applause]
[Applause]
the people are going to turn on them
they're going to protest
they're going to absolutely harass them
until they decide that they're going to
tell the president
no i can't hang with you i did not
threaten
his constituents his supporters i do
that all the time but i didn't do it
that time
this is a bunch of scumbags that's what
they
are and with this kind of inspiration
i will go and take trump out tonight
i will go and take trump out tonight
get in their faces at the grocery store
create a crowd
and go after them they're not wanted
anywhere any any time anymore
waters ocasio-cortez the rest of the
squad they now run the democratic party
they're in charge
schumer pelosi biden are deathly afraid
of them
and now they're on a mission to not only
defund the police but now dismantle and
eliminate the police in america
but we know what happens when police are
defunded don't we
or they're forced to pull back or afraid
to do their job
look at these numbers you should pay
attention in the city of atlanta my old
hometown
murder is up 58 percent new york city
murders up
40 percent even defunding efforts in
milwaukee guess what
homicides there went up a whopping 97
percent
in chicago murders this year alone are
up 33 percent
over last year's record increase we've
been scrolling the names of murder
victims shooting victims in chicago for
years
when biden was vice president obama's
hometown and he was president
we scrolled names you never heard of
before we begged for action
they didn't lift a finger in obama's
hometown can anyone tonight can you name
the latest round of murder victims in
chicago
because there were 26 people shot this
weekend five are dead
a seven-year-old little girl was
murdered in a mcdonald's drive-thru
is anybody paying attention do you know
her name tonight
those are important lives too we what
about the 103 policemen so far
this year in this country that have died
most of them
shot and killed in the line of duty
their lives matter too their families
lives matter
make no mistake when police are vilified
when they are defunded
uh when they're severely restricted when
they're dismantled
every american will suffer that won't
end well
we'll monitor the situation on the
ground in minneapolis all night